[Music]
everybody going in wake up early in the
morning press play and let's get it
in cause we rocking with the fighter
[Music]
nobody who has a real job gets paid
enough yeah no like nurses
teachers yeah easy on teachers money
they gotta start posting teachers
teachers teachers nurses yo take care of
sick people then do a podcast
yeah yeah yeah yeah that'd be a fun
podcast
especially during covert oh man mayor
james i was telling you about passed
away last night
oh debbie's so bad yeah
man i'm really i'm really good with kids
i am i would let you watch my kids yeah
i'm good with kids man
it's it's right it's easy ooh again
you're
training back in so you're the guy that
rents a ferrari for a day i'm like
this thing's easy but then you gotta pay
the maintenance you gotta change out the
tires oh it's true i don't have to pay
anything for those kids
you're right okay hold on you're doing
that you wouldn't i don't have to pay
anything
because yeah the parents would just yeah
they give me the money man every time
these kids in my neighborhood oh yeah
i didn't know didn't know i'm about to
say something i'm not every time
i just introduced you honestly yeah
brother all the way from new york
giannis what's going on man
thanks for having me new studios
i mean it's almost like this sets for me
this is my i'm a greek so this is my
yeah it's like this is comfortable for
me how was how was uh life in
you've been in l.a how long now like a
week i've been here a week but
uh i've been staying with tim dillon so
it's
my neighbor yeah a little bit of my
neighbor yeah you guys are close up
there
close that's my brother timmy yeah you
guys are away you guys are close to the
fires
away from the corona we're out of the
chaos yeah we're out of the chaos
yeah but and you came out here just to
do like uh the the pod run
i came out do a pod run are you are you
just doing it just to say what's up or
you got
some well it's because rogan i just like
yeah he was like you're gonna be in
austin i was like yeah i live in austin
now
so let's do it i don't but i was just oh
yeah that's everyone
i was like i'm here that's everyone yeah
you do wednesday 8 30 like
yeah that's easy you look at fly you're
like yeah i'll take seven layovers
can you be here tonight i'd be like yeah
i just got to be like there's no flights
i'm like i'm getting on that [ __ ]
open it up put me on your [ __ ] flight
that was your first time on rogan first
time how was it it was amazing you
almost did four hours
oh no it must have went well yeah you
know it's a shitty podcast if it's like
an
hour and 20 or hours yeah whenever i see
the time like ooh
must not have went one yeah there was
like some huge celeb who just had an
hour
right right like jamie foxx like you got
30 minutes doug yeah oh yeah here's the
shorts yeah
he like hustled sunglasses joe would ask
some questions like thanks for asking
joe
how'd i grow up listen these blue
blockers oh yeah
oh blue blockers those are [ __ ] so you
went texas then you came out to l.a i
came to l.a so i've been here and yeah
did a couple of the uh the uh old
staples here did the
whiskey ginger yes
santino cheetos santino made you again
like basically the pope mobile
yeah we did the interview yeah we're
sitting between uh fiberglass we both
had it
he's already had it yeah yeah you guys
can make out
yeah i was trying to tell him but he
didn't even we didn't even say we didn't
even do the fist bump the corona fist
bump
weird yeah so it's like the corona bro
fizzy yeah by the way i miss handshakes
dude
yeah like yeah but not like whiteness
we can't lose weight like dude that's
the thing about corona i'm worried about
dude like if that happens we'll be
talking about black handshakes the way
they used to talk about jazz like
you [ __ ] lost our focus please say
hello to your teammate
if lebron can't say hello to his
teammates i don't wanna do those sweet
handshakes
it is rigid i go for the corona bro hug
now i hug it up
people treat it like a leopard it's
weird like it's weird i was like uh
kevin hart got it right by not telling
anybody until after he's like yeah i had
it like six months ago yeah it's the new
bed bugs really
yeah if you have it like you're like
should i tell people like she was over
here last night and then you're like
i don't think i'm dirty
i didn't know it's funny that you [ __ ]
up huh i was pretty [ __ ] up
how many days i was like three weeks oh
yeah
at the hospital i went to the house i
had the real rona yeah
the real one uh yeah wow three weeks
yeah i had the one that people like
when the people who don't think it's
real going like really were you really
sick
yeah and then they go were you taking
vitamins i'm like yeah yeah i was taking
you know they're like
you sure you were taking you weren't
taking zinc like yeah i'm not sure zinc
knocks it out you know
did you wash your mouth and mystery yeah
i was brushing my teeth too and they're
like
did you try sure wasn't a
no thank god it was i had the gi version
so what happened was my sodium levels
dropped down
because you get so dehydrated and i
couldn't eat anything
so it was like i had to chew the chicken
like i was trying to chew chicken soup
and then i would have to drink water to
push it down and i couldn't even get it
down so
i lose weight though a lot yeah it's a
nice weight loss
it is nice i came out sexy saying with
tim so this is what's going on
you know you you live with tim you eat
like tim yeah but for [ __ ] two weeks
i was
sexy as [ __ ] sharp jawline i was back i
was on clown up in it was nice
taking the shirt off i needed to do a
couple clown klonopins just to get some
sleep i was a little scared
i it was scary because like i have a
newborn so i think the anxiety was part
of it too
how old's your uh at the time she was
three weeks old
ooh that new new new new and i was
quarantining at the history hyena studio
so i was like and then wifey was waking
up with a kid although my wife was
taking the kid and the mother-in-law i
was worried i gave it to them i gave it
to colin quinn
which also made me nervous [ __ ] i was
like a legend
i was like i don't want to be the guy
that kills colin quinn yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah man so it was rough
because he was on our podcast akash gave
it to me it's a whole thing
okay schultz got it i got it um you know
everybody gets it everybody got it marky
gag kind of how it goes
because like why i think it came from
brian because he's older he gave it to
me
then i gave it to chin and gave it to my
brother so write a passage yeah
yeah it's just kind of you just got to
get kind of you got to get through it
yeah yeah yeah
wait so you were you were [ __ ] up the
whole three weeks i was no
it's weird how it happens man when you
get it i was worn down i think that's
probably why i got so sick because i was
sleeping like two hours a night
immunity is already down immune system's
down
um so i was fat because my wife was
pregnant
so like mozzarella sticks was the herd
cravings so it's just like
we ate we ate mozzarella i was fat i was
like 2 30.
and then craving by the way it's a good
one yeah and um
so yeah i was run down and then um yeah
so it starts out where you feel okay so
the first couple of days you're like ah
this is gonna be nuts and then that
second wave of inflammation when your
body goes like what the [ __ ] that's when
i got hit
and i had the gi version there's a gi
version of where it gets into your gi
tract that's what my girl got and it's
[ __ ] up supposed to be worse yeah
supposed to be worse
and then did it worse yeah i had
headache driving
it was like a new symptom every day i
had this back pain that was weird mine
was weird it was like my
my headache was like here like you know
yeah that's what i felt
i'm talking it's like a [ __ ] like
some just throbbing
yeah but just like here nowhere else
just on the front
yeah did you lose taste or smell didn't
lose it thank god if i did if i had lost
taste and smell on top of like the
not being able to even think about food
that would have been brutal dude the
only thing that like
that would have put me over the top
thank god you got out of here yeah yeah
but if i didn't go to the hospital
um then i could have been in a coma or
been in icu
jesus yeah yeah you were super um i was
lucky i just went to the hospital
because
the emt came and they took my numbers
and they're like your numbers are okay i
was like i don't know man i feel
weird like i felt like weak and like
it's like it's up to you
and then you go there and they're like
overwhelmed so you kind of get treated
like a soldier i would imagine a soldier
that's the way a soldier gets treated
like yeah they check your lungs you're
like i had double pneumonia too
which is just like double demolish just
a fancy word for like inflammation in
your yeah but that's what corona causes
right double pneumonia
but they just kind of like they take
your oxygen and if you're not low they
kind of just go like go home and walk it
off
you know and like we got to keep yeah
yeah i treat the people that really yeah
yeah but you're like i need someone to
be night like i needed like
they were being mean and i was like am i
gonna be okay like i really found out
how much of a [ __ ] i'm a [ __ ]
i'll be a [ __ ] yeah i am a big [ __ ]
yeah
there's a reason why like comedians just
comedians we it's just not a good thing
to catch if you're a comedian
you're neurotic already you think too
much ready about yourself and it was
like all that came out
and i was just like what are my fans
gonna think yeah
[Laughter]
yeah it's just that's scared and yeah
how's the dad life the dad life's
amazing man i don't trust the kid yet i
haven't known it that long but
people like oh you're gonna love it
instantly i'm like this kid has done
nothing for me nothing
you don't trust me yeah you don't know i
just had a conversation with you
i've been on a podcast with you right
trust me i would [ __ ] give you my
wallet right
i would be sure that that wallet would
be i'm not don't trust that [ __ ] baby
hell we don't know he hasn't done a
thing for me yet it's a it's a girl a
little girl it's a girl yeah
so how how old is she now like she's
three months
sorry i'm being honest it's true though
i mean i'm supposed to love it right
away
yeah no no the moms have to love it
right the moms do
yeah the mom's right away there's
interconnection for the dads it's like
this weird football with eyes
it's like wait what am i gonna do with
it yeah like they need the mom
so bad yeah they do they are you waking
up in the night and [ __ ] in the mornings
i just no i just kind of don't tell my
wife i still have corona and i get out
of it tight move yeah she's like it's
your turn i'm like i got covet
that was two months ago i'm like [ __ ]
i'm a long hauler leave me alone
my finger hurts like that's the symptom
i'm like yeah just google it because if
you google
anything it's a [ __ ] cigarette yeah
you don't find it you can say it's like
yeah they
read it there's long haulers yeah she's
like those people are 65 and have cancer
and i'm like that's not the case
y'all listen dr powell every day yeah
every [ __ ] day so i have new york's
opening up new york city cuomo came out
was like listen man
these lockdowns are terrible we gotta
open up businesses because when we come
back we're gonna open up doesn't mean
enough to come back to like
all right change of mind everyone's all
upset i'm like nah as long as you open
up i don't care
yeah of course the politicians are
two-faced oh really
yeah and it need they need money they
need business so it's like it's funny
that they're legalizing gambling and
legalizing i think they're because
everyone's fled new york so the tax base
is gone everyone's gone to the suburbs
you go there it's like
[ __ ] you know that movie uh escape
from new york yeah it looks like that
it's like kurt russell just like [ __ ]
climbing over a bridge yeah yeah and uh
so they everyone's flee they need it
they need to tax something so they're
legalizing marijuana they're legalizing
i'm sure the legalizing prostitution if
you go there now it looks like they've
legalized like
being able to hit people with machetes
and bricks that [ __ ] is happening right
yeah it's the purge dude if you any day
you read the local news it's like there
was a guy naked in brooklyn and he had a
machete and he
he he chopped four people yeah the
murder rate in new york
was like 127 of some [ __ ] there was some
like cuomo staffer had nothing to do
with her being a cuomo staffer but some
guy just came and hit her with a brick
like 1980s new york crimes are happening
right now
yes the boys the brick out of nowhere
just bang people losing their [ __ ]
people
are crazy starving and like it's like
yeah the
the girl she's in new york she's the
voice of the the daughter
on rick and morty she was just sat like
a bodega and some dude
came with a machete and [ __ ] yeah man
hit up her man in her yeah
didn't kill him but [ __ ] them up yeah
it's it's like why it's weird i don't
know
yeah it's just great people just while
what kind of [ __ ] is going on
new york you could you probably use you
as an example right like you're a comic
now you're very funny you're doing this
but like so new york was like having a
good era right it was like doing it you
know kind of
but that [ __ ] [ __ ] is always in new
york it's like if you
talk [ __ ] to brendan he'll [ __ ] you up
you know yeah yeah you can laugh and
joke at him yeah it'll come out so it's
like new york
in the 80s where i grew up was like
danger like dangerous and that's right
and that's like joking and then now it's
just like all right we're doing this
again
yeah and that was like new york when
they filmed the joker yes like that era
like new york just being rough from yeah
you used to be a bodyguard in new york
right
at bodyguard does he look like you read
the word you read the wrong wikipedia
page
[Applause]
who wants to talk to chad
uh
how tough i am i moved to the country
some dude was setting off fireworks
i thought it was an active shooter
situation i called the cops and crawled
on the ground
they came and they said man that doesn't
happen around here
works you [ __ ] it's 5 000 people in this
town they're giving out burgers
i was crawling on the floor in the
garage yeah it's a true story
because i grew up in brooklyn yeah and
then i just moved to the country in like
a really quiet area how far from like
brooklyn is that
hour and a half oh yeah i moved out
there's horses and [ __ ]
oh yeah i'm living in the country came
up but when i got up there i was like
you you it's funny because in the city
it's much more dangerous but you're
comfortable we all
everyone in new york has stockholm
syndrome everyone's walking around this
is great you eat food that has rapists
on it yeah and then you get in the train
some guy's got his ass out and he hands
you [ __ ]
yeah you're like this is great new york
new york
yeah everybody else is just like [ __ ]
sweating on the train you're all this is
great
subway yeah it's so great how much is
dinner 500
amazing yeah so uh yeah i moved out to
the country and it's funny like i don't
like i'm scared now like
animals and [ __ ] animals yeah what a gun
i got a [ __ ] gun i'm strapped
and before that i was like gun control
stop it another school shooting america
what is going on i hate the guns now you
got an ar-15 yeah i'm like
get off my lawn [ __ ] there you
go yeah
[Applause]
[ __ ] communists are taking over this
country brother
democracy yeah it just happened yeah you
know what it is like changes
it's like nobody wants to take context
into consideration like if you live
in new york i could understand why
everyone can't have guns okay
because everyone's on top of each other
yeah so like if you're on the train in
the morning
somebody pushes you and [ __ ] end like
a quentin tarantino movie everyone's
just pulling out
and everyone's dead but if you live in a
[ __ ] country and somebody's breaking
in your house
you can't rely on the car you can't call
the cops and be like hey hey man
someone's breaking in
where's your house okay what you got to
do is you know there's a river
yeah there's a crew waiting for you on
the riverbank then get in that and you
know that tree where the eagle on top of
it
i mean you know just let them off we'll
be there for 50 minutes
yeah so yeah are the gun laws
crazy in new york you can get a rifle
you can get like you can't get a conceal
so it's like the the lawsuit
it's kind of strict but it's like it's
strict here too yeah
but i just walked into a dick's and
bought a 22 yeah
yeah yeah he's in the country now he
could buy it do you have to wait though
didn't they still make you wait a couple
days
no they did not yeah yeah yeah you
didn't yeah that's
that's the it just you just walk in and
me and my buddy paul version he's a
comic very funny
version yeah he's a monster yeah one day
he just walked up he was like let's get
some guns done
everyone's watching the news like our
country's falling apart get some [ __ ]
guts
yeah so we just went to dick's he told
his wife we were gonna get coffee we
came back with guns she's like what the
[ __ ] are you guys doing like we got guns
now
yeah yeah yeah yeah she's cool with it
yeah yeah i mean she's like the family
yeah that history of uh hyenas money man
moving out to the country
yeah trying yeah trying yeah you guys
are balling we're doing okay
how are you gonna do the show thanks to
you and a lot of people let us on and
shoot yeah
we [ __ ] love you guys he has a show
new york's interesting man because
you have like schultzy out there who's
been doing the podcast obviously he took
the podcast game over
but then a lot of you guys you guys just
these monster comics
yeah like i guess we'll try podcasting
like six weeks ago
yeah and then now all you guys are
blowing up yeah like tim dillon was like
i'll do podcasts
turn the mic on yeah just [ __ ] spits
pure fire
yeah it's like one of the biggest in the
game yeah well we looked at you guys
like
the ones of us who were smart and we're
like what's going on here what like
we're saying we're like
doing sets for 25 i'm an artist man
you know it's like are you are you james
joyce
who are just like you know understanding
they're in show business
i'm poor but i'm [ __ ] i'm being true
to me
like shut the [ __ ] up dude your lights
are off yeah
man but your lights are off i want to
come over and meet my six roommates
i'm 47. but i'm me yeah so how
so how are you guys gonna do especially
you you're gonna do set how you gonna do
it now
what you're gonna drive into town what
are you gonna do yeah yeah driving to
town yeah
i got a half though dude that's to get
in the city it's an hour you're gonna
drive an hour i'll drive and i got it
every night i got a tesla
oh
the internet is nice right now yeah yeah
i mean i was supposed to be in a tv show
and i got covered and then they still
wanted me after the show
and they were like uh yeah he wants you
back to do the show and i was like
i'm going to do rogan like no yeah no
it's like definitely okay man i'm coming
out to l.a you know he's like coming out
to la babe love to get on the show like
yeah let's do it man this is months ago
then he's like yeah i'm just trying to
line up
uh you know i'm shooting i'm gonna be
shooting this tv show down there i'm
like
oh who's it where it's all true tv i
went
um are you living in 2000 yes
[Laughter]
are you doing a plane
he's like yeah man there's still money
in tv i said yeah there's money working
at costco too
yeah you gotta go get it
that's why so many guys are conditioned
man i know especially here in l.a too
like everyone wants that
that co-sign of hollywood for for
whatever reason i don't get it man
i guess it's cause like uh that's how
you grew up you feel like you want to
you know you know you know it's almost
like too good to be true
this is like um we're sitting here we
didn't prep we're having a great time
we're laughing i think a lot of people
be like this can't be
it's like you know when you're stealing
money and like you're going like people
maybe they're just going like this not
true right yeah no dude
have you seen brendan chop's car yeah
it's true
i've seen it i touched it it's like it's
real dude
it's real but it's like
he's talking this comic tim dylan's
producer's driving a [ __ ] tesla yeah
tim tim dylan was at the comedy store in
the groom i guess
they were talking about something some
one of the comics not from here was kind
of [ __ ] on me
yeah and he was giving tim advice and
tim's like well shop says do this like
dude he doesn't know what the tim goes
yeah i'm listening to guy that drives a
frying ass and barn
where's your man where's your museum
i'll be performing on a rooftop at 12.50
and then you can catch me at whitney
cummings backyard at 12 67.
yeah yeah it's made up of time 12. i
guess
while we're thinking we're [ __ ]
artists why don't we just call it 1267
while we're at it i guess tim set him up
like this he's like yeah cool yeah no
that's good advice
what card are you trying the guy's like
a rav4 he's like i'm gonna listen to
brandon yeah yeah
yeah anyone who drives the same car as
the guy that [ __ ] was and make a
murderer i'm not to listen to you
that was the worst press for the rab4
ever yeah
they sucked before yeah dude that was
like [ __ ] wild
like wild horses is a good song yeah you
know and like
uh silence of the lambs killed that song
you know that song
yeah mm-hmm uh what is it doing
and then you just can't listen to it
without going hard for me you know
it's a good song yeah good buffalo bill
yeah yeah that's his name yeah yeah
looks like theon
he does yeah he looks a little like does
he yeah he does or is she a great big
fap
[Laughter]
you pulling them up buffalo bill buffalo
science of the lands
if you just type buffalo bill you get
some old cowboy from the [ __ ] 1600
likes all skinny as [ __ ] too that
movie's so good man
silence on the limbs yeah right there
there he is yeah it looks like fear when
he's losing his hair look at steel if he
didn't have a wig
when he's in the yeah right there that's
that part
[Laughter]
and that's where he's listening to the
song yeah
she's a perfect fat person
he has the night vision goggles on where
do you think you could have done that
yeah the final fight scene with jody
foster yeah
johnny beats his is that called uh the
uh
the bulldog no the one you talk about i
call it [ __ ]
i called the bulldog because when you
tuck it you're nuts hanging out the back
yeah yeah you can do that too yeah yeah
that's a good one
i like that one the bulldog yeah sure
you could do that i guess
yeah so how you so how are you so you're
gonna drive in with your tesla to new
york to do sets yeah i like it because
like you can
like you can text with that it's great
while you're dressed yeah self-driving
and then
you can live dangerously didn't a bunch
of them get recalled though
i guess so but i don't want to hear
about that
about yours right yeah yeah yeah that's
right only way to clean out your spam
email while you're
putting everyone's life at risk mcallen
got one of the first edition ones and he
was
me and him were doing a show in brea and
he was like dude this thing dr is
one of the very first ones that this
thing drives by itself and we're in
we're going down [ __ ]
405. he's going 90s like watch this dude
it's a thing he's like look at me
he's like you can't
but you know it's nice on those nights
where it's like you know that slow
annoying drizzle you guys don't have
water out here
you know when it rains it rains yeah
yeah so when it's like dangerous i just
yeah i just put the [ __ ]
i just feel safer yeah i drive safer
yeah but how are you going to do the
podcast you can do zooms
no we've been doing it we have a studio
so we the student is in manhattan
studios in brooklyn so my old apartment
we just turned into a studio oh
yeah yeah but it's a co-op so i'm a
little i don't know how long we're gonna
do it
because co-op the co-op board is like i
the super reason was like hey man
uh i need to check your radiators and i
kind of was like oh [ __ ]
somebody heard chris and stefano yelling
you know i'm i like
men or whatever so yeah we got so then
you
you come down you shoot at once a week
we do once a week
and do you knock out two in the same way
we knock out two in the same day right
there and then yeah it's the hard work
of a comedian in 2021 we're done that's
what's going on yeah yeah have you been
touring at all during these games
and i don't miss it i don't miss it hold
on before you
how long have you been doing stand up
though long time 15 years
you just did a special uh blowing the
light yeah produced by andrews
yeah sure yeah it was on the line that's
right yeah
it's still collecting views yeah that's
a great thing about the internet youtube
it's just up
yeah just up that was that's why
specials on tv
it's over because it's like you watch it
and then netflix is still good because
it's up but it
people forget netflix is the internet
it's not tv no it's like
it's stream it's streaming yeah it's
like it's got to stay up it can't just
air and then be gone no because you can
get new fans yeah
yeah if it's just straight network tv
like uh if you don't
if you don't watch it on friday night
nine it's over you know yeah
like uh they just released my half hour
on comedy central from 2013
and i've just been posting them on my
instagram they used to take them down
but now i think comedy central is like
over
so they're not they used to just they
had like uh some sort of algorithm that
found
yes and took it down but now they're
leaving up so i'm cutting it up and
putting it up
right cool with it are they not cut are
they cutting it up on their instagram
too no they put the whole thing up on
youtube
but then i was like let me try cause i
kept trying to put them up yeah
and then they would take them down so i
put it up maybe they're gonna take them
down now but it was like
putting them up on instagram i should
keep my mouth shut
they're probably watching this going
like how is this how can we turn comedy
central into this now
pretty soon you can say welcome to
comedy central and then it's just going
to be [ __ ] a podcast yeah
yeah comedy central is under a different
management now so they're probably like
man if he posts what are we going to do
with yeah
[ __ ] material i guess they don't care
anymore i mean why would they it's like
this helps
it's a clip that would send people to go
watch the whole special see i i think
there's still
a huge uh opportunity for a comedy
central like you look at their like
digital platform like their their
social media and their especially
youtube's huge yeah
it's like [ __ ] your your network tv yeah
that's whatever yeah but if digital like
putting special on did like norman
knight
or no no samurai did it yeah there's
been a few people that do it there man
yeah and sam's got
it got millions of views yeah it did
yeah yeah i mean norman did it on him
did norman do a comment on his own
yeah he got like five million right now
yeah he's a monster
he's a machine yeah it's crazy because
they're like yeah netflix he's like
netflix showtime
everyone turned me down like how the
[ __ ] does that happen it's just the era
where
uh yeah i don't know if they're looking
for the most experienced comics anymore
they're kind of looking for you gotta
have a story
yeah i've got some yeah
so i got to start pushing my story more
if i wanted to get
your origin story nah just is it a cool
story though you got to be a victim man
it's like i got i've been shot
which is you know you've been shot i've
been shot so yeah i never talk about
that
how are you i was a social worker for
five years i helped people and who shot
you yeah
um it was an attempted robbery but i got
shot
black grains yeah point blank range i
got shot see melanie where are you he
was like that's when you were a
bodyguard
they always come back
then oh that's right yeah yeah it was
pretty tough in yellowstone
i do love when rogan posts those fake
karate videos that [ __ ] is always
hilarious when he goes the guy's going
like that
and then you see a real fight in ufc
it's like mostly wrestling and like yeah
that's not how it goes
like so you just got shot you were uh
yeah so i was like
when i first started how long was this
this was 2001
2001. so i first i had like that's when
i started doing new york was crazy
because new york was fine which was good
new york had started
new york started to change like in the
mid uh 90s the club that i worked at was
[ __ ] wild it was like the night was
just a wild night
um it was you can actually there's a
story the what
something else that happened at that
club was there was like this really
famous director who was coming up
and uh he was like walking home one
night and somebody
got shot in their car at that club at
that party that night
and he decided to drive and then he died
while he was driving and he just hit
that guy walking that was the end of his
life
soho new york the club is called envy
dude your origin story is pretty cool
keep yeah i gotta start pushing that
yeah
so it was gang related you know yeah for
them it was no i'm not for me that was
how he knew
he started he started inducing all right
or you want the real score
yeah at the time i was like you know i
was helicoptering over darfur
and saving children you know and you
take some fire but for the kids you know
it wasn't i didn't even feel it
because what i was doing was such a
humanitarian car
you know i don't know if it was the
adrenaline or my heart i think part of
it was my heart for the kids
i was able to get six kids out they have
both their limbs
six kids i was holding three in each arm
and you know they were easier to hold
because they didn't have all their arms
they have all that that's really mean
i'm sorry but you know they were
mining for diamonds and i was able to
save it i took
one bullet actually it's too few
yeah it wasn't sexy at all like that my
my friend hurt like a
mother burns it doesn't hurt the
adrenaline takes care of you man
it's wild but the having the moment
where you think you're gonna die
is uh is great it's great
[Laughter]
it's great great how did you know i was
so happy
i was like i'm never going to see anyone
again i'm going to die
it's a great moment i've been waiting
for him
where'd that come from because he was
drawing it was hilarious
it was really fun how did you know
that's like the last word you described
if there was the opposite of great
what's the opposite of great
oh look at that he's looking absolutely
horror yeah absolutely
that was so authentic
raping your [ __ ] that's great right
great moment right
he ripped it right yes which is great
it's a great boy yeah
that's hilarious um he shot me it was a
point it was point blank range so i was
with my uh
my friend who was a party promoter he
carried a lot of cash with him out of
the party he's
stupid yeah so um he would have a
bouncer bodyguard walk with him
to the car so the guy walked us to the
car i remember put a box of flyers in
the
uh you know he's a club promoter in the
backseat and then
uh he walked away went around the corner
and then as i was getting in the
passenger side seat
i saw the guy coming he had a mask on
gloves and a gun and i was like [ __ ]
i made a decision to try to get in the
car and tell him to drive
but the kid kind of sped up and then he
kind of fell into the car
in the passenger seat and then like i
saw the gun and i just grabbed his arm
and like pushed it down and he fired and
i got hit right here
in the inside leg like that's a bad spot
to get hit yeah but thank god my piece
is not that big so it's just
one time i was happy to have a tiny
piece
a lot of people don't know in like 2012
years ahead of your time with the
transgender comedy
yeah that that's something that i'm
probably gonna take down in 2020
yeah it was huge bailey's trying to get
you you know
i actually thought it was funny yeah you
want to hear a funny story that time you
said sandy hook was fake
about that i mean those were the days
wasn't selling out up oh yes yeah i was
and uh so yeah back then it was like
before cancer coach people were just
like
funny yeah and that character you know
that character was big
with get in the genki they still do it
yeah when they do like drag shows and
[ __ ]
like i've people send me videos all the
time of like performers funny though
doing her
words like that's it i say i'm going to
watch
and it was like all puerto ricans black
cuban it was massive and uh so i would
do live shows and do her and
it was [ __ ] great if it wasn't for
marissa we would never have cardi b
cardi b was the stripper in the bronx
when when that was happening
and that like the owner of that club
wanted me to come to do that character
she's no question she saw it bro i
remember once she posted on her
instagram
being at bbq oh yeah she that was a in
new york it was like there was a couple
years mauricio was like
like j.lo and mark anthony were doing
like some morning show
and they wanted to meet me what yeah
people they were all what miami and new
york
it was exploded for you were you like i
guess i want a career in this
like playing this drag queen all my
transgendered get it right
right
you're a [ __ ] nerd
it's getting confusing out there yeah
identify this man during certain moods
and then yeah it's going to get weird
can't mix up yeah but i've been weird
for you being like just this huge
success but you're playing this
transgender here's the thing like yeah i
didn't have any success
so like and none of my friends did so my
generation was like soda nate bargatsi
uh that was my generation of guys so i
was like the first guy to sell tickets
and it was off the internet i shot that
video in my room
so that was still the time where none of
us really believed in the internet we
were still going like gotta get montreal
gotta do the half hour so then i did
montreal
new faces i did the half hour and it was
like i got zero from that nothing
like zero you get paid like 20 grand for
the half hour you give 10 to your
manager 10 your agent and then
you get nothing but like this video i
shot in my [ __ ]
living room i was selling out everywhere
well selling out new york
yeah miami san francisco yeah yeah yeah
you were moving so i was just happy to
have something and be making money
and also i had another character that
was popular so if it was just maurice
it would be tough it might be a little
tough but i had mr panos who was a great
guy
he was doing good with the greeks so i
would go to the greek shows
you know it's funny i started to put
them both together in the show
because i would do stand-up and then i
would do maurica
right and nobody was there to see me no
so like at those morissa shows i'd do my
stand-up they would just kind of deal
with it and then they're like bring out
the queen and then they'd come out
you see the women dude they loved her
yeah they thought she was real she went
that's right tell them you want to go to
washington and then i was saying they
were oh
[ __ ] i'm so sad
like latin women get dressed up for the
[ __ ] when did you retire the
character
i have it it's [ __ ] i'll be in long
island in five years
i'll be smoking a cigarette be like all
right all you got to do is crack my back
i go out there and give you five dots
inch i got my money up front yeah
i mean i retired that [ __ ] you're crazy
yeah okay i don't know i'm gonna start a
fan's only page for i'm gonna [ __ ]
get
i'll live is her i mean you never know
i've never been as big as her
yeah bulldog you're not yeah
yeah but i had him and so then i had a
video
he was big with the greeks and then i
did this greek financial crisis video
that got really big
with the financial people and
internationally so like it was weird
like
because it used to just be greeks and
like eastern europeans that liked
mr panos but then that financial video
was in like a documentary about
uh when greece was in the financial
crisis it was in a book
and then financial guys started hiring
me to do like shows
oh wow birthdays corporate shows
corporate like hedge fund guys because
it was a fine
big boy that's money i mean the money
was like it's when you
when i try to explain to my kid what i
do yeah on like parent teacher day i'm
going to like bring the maurice the wig
and just put it on
daddy makes money your daddy's a doctor
your daddy is playing a trance from the
lower
east suddenly and then he pulls the
mustache
so yeah i remember showing up to one guy
just like 20 grand in cash
and then i did what he just handed me
another grand like because he enjoyed it
and were you going back with like soda
and the rest and nate no no no
fellas i was just bald and back then it
wasn't that much money but i was like
the first one to make
money and then yeah and then i took a tv
job which was stupid
crushed yourself i went to fusion it was
a new network called fusion
and they were in miami and at that time
i was dating jessie may peluso
we were like living together and then
she blew up on girl code and started
exploding on girl code his mtv show
and uh i was i couldn't take it so i
just took this job in miami they offered
it first i turned it down
because i was like we're gonna live
together we're gonna be married and then
she was like i gotta go on the road and
then she just [ __ ] blew
past my career and i was like i gotta
get out of this town i can't i couldn't
see her success i was so
jealous oh wow yeah so you were you were
younger no i'm older than her
well i'm just saying at the time you're
like i was younger you were more
immature
much more uh i
this was uh 2013 so i was in my 30s i
should have known
yeah should have been
still had those childish emotions in my
teen years you're right yeah for sure i
was in my church
how old are you 35 i was 40 years old
yeah it was
really childish yeah yeah you can't
handle it man i couldn't handle it yeah
i couldn't handle it which is [ __ ]
looking back i'm like what a dick i was
i know
yeah you know i should have been happy
for her but i was so in love with her at
the time
uh and we broke up and then so i took
this job in miami of fusion and like
this was like the last
they'll never that was like probably the
last launch of a network that'll never
happen again
they put like hundreds of millions of
dollars into it it was owned by disney
abc news univision came together they
built this network they built this
massive studio
and it was the time where 2013 where you
didn't need that anymore it was like
kids were using their phones already
it was like so what was your gig on
there we had a like a
news comedy show so it was me and two
like legit journalists
one they were trying to do like the
diversity kind of so he was a brazilian
news journalist like a real one and a
model he's like massively famous in
brazil
and she was a venezuelan uh journalist
who was like a peabody award-winning
and i was like the comic relief so we
did like a
news show funny show they we went on
good morning america we went on uh
kellyanne and michael
they were promoting because it was
disney and it was yeah abc news they
were pushing us but
nothing i mean the show i was there a
year the show got cancelled did it pay
well
it paid well decently at the time you
know for me it paid well but
it got nothing dude nothing and you just
it just set me back a year
yeah well you're not working on like you
and not on the yeah you're not
on stand yeah getting fans and [ __ ] it's
just like i'm sitting there getting a
paycheck but nobody was watching it
a lot of 13 followers in a year from
that ship yeah
yeah yeah a lot of comics in la fall in
that trap
they write for shows but the writing is
such a demand that they're not really
doing their own [ __ ]
right just writing for other people
right and they get done with that show
and like god
[ __ ] over that you're gonna figure i
gotta work on me now yeah
well everybody else has just been doing
that yeah yeah
so like you guys really led the way on
that in la we started looking over
you know and new york's got that thing
where new york thinks it's the greatest
yeah was that a fortress
right
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'll give you three yes
you say was it the thick one on the left
i just powered through yeah
like this
i knew it wasn't like oh spd that you
that like slipped out because that would
have had more of a it would have more of
a high pitch
because you know when you you
he adjusted his posture
[Laughter]
brother really
done it without all kind of all that
[ __ ] is nate bargaski yes
i feel like he's the last one you know
who knows what happens with netflix but
you know i've seen people blow up on
there but nate barber gats he got hit on
like
he just hit like the right the right
stride the right algorithm and just
because we talk about people blown up
off specials yeah it's like
him segura joe coy off netflix like
oh yeah she was like the last one before
and nate yeah
nate really blew up and i i i've never
met him before we know
we know of each other and he was doing a
set in the main room i was
he had to i was on before him thank god
i had to go before him
and uh he was the nicest [ __ ] guy
he was so sweet me and nate started guys
so me
me and nate actually had a podcast
together what in 2009 we did it all
wrong
but if we had done it right it probably
would have just the timing what do you
mean
you've done it all wrong we did it all
wrong like we didn't do it every week
not consistent
not consistent the sound was shitty you
know it was so early back then i think
only burr had a podcast maybe rogan just
started his
yeah probably rogan it was like 2008.99
so we did it for a couple years but
it was bad and we had like a little fan
base but then we stopped it
but uh yeah nate is such a good comic
stand up
i mean it's just like it's natural yeah
yeah he doesn't curse he's clean
i know but he's one of those clean guys
that you're like you're laughing you're
like this [ __ ] is honest
unique he's such a beast he just he
makes the audience kind of come to his
rhythm which is slow and
you get into it and like that's it
that's it yeah yeah i got nervous
because uh lucia
she's uh you know the manager at zany's
in nashville
she was like oh is steel come like
theo's coming and she's like oh uh
nate bargaski's up the street should we
call him and i got nervous
[Laughter]
killer man
yeah he's doing like because like he's
clean so yeah if you're clean
he's doing everything like guys again
that's it that's it and seinfeld
gaffigan's no brian regan monster
and those guys make bangs oh jim
gaffigan's like big oh yeah
yeah he's like yeah he'll come and
you'll see him like he's so humble
coming to like uh
do a set at the stand or whatever and
then like
he'll do like 10 minutes he never goes
over he's really respectful of other
comics
he's so respectful people forget like oh
that and then this dude's going tomorrow
to do
a arena of white people in wisconsin
i'm making his haunted money a ton of
money so you look at his crowd he looks
like you're performing in sweden
yeah dude him and i have never met but
we uh dm'd each other back and forth
like he had a special come out he said
you know can you post this something
like that
and so we were talking on instagram
never
spoke a word to him and then i was in
the belly room and the
shoulder came back she's like hey do you
mind if we bump you we got we got a
special guest i'm like yeah i don't care
and i'd even ask him to get whatever
whatever you want me to go on
and then i i hear a large man behind me
go hello
instagram buddy there's jim gaffney
he's hello instagram buddy you mind if i
go up yeah what's your thing man
he's so clean but once in a while he'll
uh he'll slip in like a dirty one when
he's
working out kind of the one joke one
joke i remember he was just at like some
bar he goes around and works out in the
city where he just loves works
workshops and one joke i'd never forget
because it was just like coming out of
gaff in his
mouth you know it was like a couple
years ago and he was like you know i
think we have
too many celebrities now he goes you
know what we gotta just go
hey you you gotta go back to just being
a [ __ ]
did you see like obviously he's super
respectful
and like humble dude and real nice but
then you see on twitter when he lit up
neil brennan
little boy lit him up yeah then you're
like oh yeah yeah
yeah that's one of the biggest comics in
the world yeah liz like neil went at him
he's like excuse me yeah
oh well i have the time today sir yeah
and he went like yeah sorry it's not uh
i don't have a one mic to [ __ ] one
mic to tell people i know chappelle and
like it was like yeah
yeah yeah yeah he's a comic dude he's
coming i'm a comic and uh
he's so humble that's like things like
he came and did our podcast when we
first started me and chris
he came and did it we had no like he
came and did it that would be like kevin
hart i mean he doesn't read us
yeah he does arenas yeah so it's like he
that's like
kevin hart coming to do our podcast yeah
that's that's like joe coy can you
co-host him like yeah dude i'll be right
down like really yeah he's like yeah why
would i'm like i don't know because you
sold out oracle arena
seven times right right he's like i'll
be right there dude i'm driving down
from vegas i'm like
you want money or do you wanna take one
of my kids
comics so big comics are cool like that
okay
we have to kind of be like kind of stay
because you can't get too
lofty otherwise like you can't be a
comic anymore no one can what are you
gonna go and be like hey
yeah my private jet didn't start today
yeah you know people
like get your [ __ ] phone exactly yeah
do you think it's just everyone
understands like that original grind
from coming up in con comedy i think so
you know like that's what that person
is going through that's right yeah i
think you're right i think it's like
they
it's so hard yeah yeah unless you're
brendan's job and you [ __ ]
shoot up
netflix special three weeks ahead let's
go for it
come on you might have seen this guy
[Laughter]
but here he is
mma
yeah i get it i get it shop hit home
dawg
right the way you said it for the belly
that's how i was in some comments like
now [ __ ] that guy
do you think you deserve like i don't
know do you think maybe you should
switch up your material
if it hasn't worked in 20 years and why
are you paying attention with somebody
else's debts
i stole your special yeah yeah yeah i
think that people feel like that
people feel like those people aren't
funding people are losing if you're
doing that you're a loser you're not
getting your money
you're not gonna make this business is
so hard if you're looking at what
somebody else is
then you're wasting your emotional
energy and time on something else
it's like you gotta focus on your own
[ __ ] there's enough cake at the table
for everybody man especially now it's
supposed to be interesting
so much you can do it used to be like
that where you had to go through
sd or the comedy store and everyone was
competing and there was a secret kind of
like there's only three
late night sets that [ __ ] is over
there's more we're helping each other
now
yeah back then it was like you were on
hbo comedy central or showtime there's
three spots
and each one gave up maybe two to three
specials a year now it's like
all right dude yeah yeah put it anywhere
you got like a hundred dollars together
yeah on youtube yeah yeah it's wide
[ __ ] open now
so it's like you should be happy
actually it's the opposite
she's like oh [ __ ] brandon shop showing
i got to get on this [ __ ] show yeah
you know what i mean like we should get
some fan like we our podcast got big
just like that
it was like we grinded me and chris had
some fans
but it was like going on these shows
going on fighters
so funny like that's a thing like you're
not gonna
you're podcasting you can do well you're
not gonna sell takes on the road if
you're not funny man
like you you know look at all the people
rogan's had on a million times or we've
had a million times
for the reasons there's just not a
connection right and you look like well
they're not funny
right it's not us it's you man figure it
out
right if you if you can't make it in
this era you may not just be funny
yeah because comics are going now like i
was on rogan the other day and he's just
like
you can tell he's going like this is it
you know you got we go long
you can't say [ __ ] i you know i wish i
had more time it's like
this is yours this is having me on now
it's like let's
let's entertain people yeah if you're
funny that's what you got in this
business to do
yeah you know so it's like and the fans
are telling you yeah you can't there's
no excuses now you used to be like
what do they know about coming and you
could be right because you're talking to
some [ __ ] executive
who was like you know whatever an
accountant the day before
and now they're deciding who's getting a
show now it's other comics yeah
going like are you funny and then like
so those are the experts in the field
there's other comics and
other comics and the fan base the fan
base going they might go all right i
watched tim dillon video then i'm
watching schultz then
shop and i'm watching giannis then i'm
going you know santino bobby lee
theovan it's like oh all this all right
yeah just go down that road yeah yeah
and they decide yeah and then you'll see
on the road if you're selling tickets if
you're not maybe not funny maybe you're
just not funny yeah and
it goes straight to the fans now yeah
and that's comedy that's what
that that's why it's always funny when
like bloggers come and review a comedy
show you're like we don't need you to do
that yeah
yeah the crowd is doing that in real
time we know it didn't go good [ __ ]
or it went good yeah and then if it goes
good you can't write an article saying
it didn't i was like
we were all in the room yeah it went
good yeah it went good but it's awesome
people pay attention to that [ __ ]
blog yeah and then they go like it must
have not gone good you're like yeah you
weren't there
yeah comedies happens live yeah yeah
it's very strange
it's strange when someone like reviews a
special or rates a special because it's
kind of like music it's like right well
that's not your cup of tea
right but that person you know has this
seven million dollar mansion from
writing those jokes right so something's
going right for that person right
right right strange right right yeah
that's exactly what i said about
nickelback
people talk so much [ __ ] about
nickelback but selling a lot of arenas
they are selling out of really old
school reference
look at leah drake look at this
photograph yeah
do you see how much you hate drake gets
oh so much hate the biggest musician in
the world the
best musician of our of uh from 2010 to
2020 yeah most streamed yeah i don't
know if you could disrespect beyonce
like that but
yeah he's the biggest male 1
you just go sit there
[Laughter]
world culture
sensitivity all right give some curt
events dude
he was sitting on that beyonce it's a
nice just a nice quaker moment of
silence right here
jay ripa fart your flashlight been on
this whole time on your phone joe oh
there you go
i thought you was giving us are those
new kicks chin uh which ones these i
thought you'd give us the like whose new
air max no i had it for a while
would you wear this uh we got a shoe
95's yeah
that's nice yeah yeah
yeah the air force ones are like the
[ __ ] again right yeah it's the [ __ ]
again
they never really go out but now they're
big yeah the kick talkers are
like uh younger the younger generation
yeah now they don't respect air force
ones they like to dirty them up
and then it was like see i like the way
shoes look better dirty too
yeah what yeah certain shoes look better
dirty i'm not the air force once
i had someone looked down you needed air
force ones you need throwaway air force
ones and then the ones that are clean
that you actually go out with
that's how i feel about airflow i think
that's so good i think so mine is
that means you're doing work in them so
you're not talking about like
skateboarding in my dunks but yeah i
like i like my [ __ ]
so what do you mean by that like what
one well you know like like if like if
j if we were walking out and jay like
scuffed the back of my shoe i wouldn't
flip out
like oh you like i would have a high
school i would flip out two i like them
clean
yeah yeah am i tripping when they look
when they look too new i like i like it
like i wear you know
i don't know my shoes yeah you went
biking and you
he had us he had us at this big boy
commercial shoot right yesterday and he
didn't tell us like i'm thinking man
should people think like it's going to
be a house or something like that
house that's what i thought i thought it
was a house i'm bringing
my off-white air force ones yeah and
that was like wait it's gonna the shoot
is in the dirt yeah i went out there in
my madagascar's flip-flops
you couldn't risk it yeah black kids are
serious about
kicks
when you go into a store like black
dudes would be like can i get those and
like we only
got those in a size eight you're like
i'm a size 12 [ __ ] give them
white guy's going like that like can i
just try the merrell's on for a second
i'm going mountain climbing with my son
i just want to see it what's the arch
support in that thing can you can you
take a measurement
is a little bigger than the right and i
just want to make sure i get the right
support and i'm a thin
feet and i want to make sure i got good
traction and then just take them for a
spin
around a little store a little bit dude
black dudes walking out with [ __ ]
bags
yeah i keep mine i like it that's why
that's why i got i think if
that's why you have to have a lot
because then you don't wear them a lot
so you like you can always keep them
fresh
yeah yeah dude so i think someone stole
my uh
atmos um air max 90s the the animal pack
ones yeah the ones that you've got what
do you mean my friend was like hey these
are the dopest cakes ever i'm like yo
those are my favorite shoes ever i wear
them
all the time like i've been wearing
those forever and i'm looking for them i
can't find them i think someone stole
them
yeah somebody said who's gonna again or
i left them in a airbnb
yeah i don't know where they're at i
know i'm heartbroken someone steal your
shoes no i do
you just misplaced it because you said
yeah i don't think so those i would not
miss
someone have the opportunity to take
your shoes yeah that's what i'm saying
airbnb
is everybody coming in airbnb are you
basically accusing them
right i was wearing it down i was like
he was kind of walking around it was
like y'all man you remember that
time we did that gig is there three of
us
you know i didn't stand i haven't really
been able to
i like how he looked at me i either lost
him
you know you ever seen star trek or like
god took him or aliens or
like y'all wouldn't know anything about
where my sneakers are right
did you guys see an alien come in or
housekeeper maybe he's got the same size
foot as me
you see when that little mexican
in there yeah that's what's crazy that's
what i can't figure out
never ask you guys because i know you
don't know anything about that there's
only the three of us in there so i would
never
try i did want to bring it up because it
really bothered me
i'd like to point
[Applause]
i can't be racist by your rules i can't
be right
you're like how puerto rican are you
like i'm half puerto rican
now you're white if you lose a black guy
you're white
dude protesting your puerto rican but if
you ask
say a black guy stole your phone you are
[ __ ] white now
okay how about the house here they go
you keep saying you're puerto rican do
you think puerto ricans can be racist
she's like no no she's like well i
most people would beg to differ
oh god oh my god the video was funny how
hysterical she was oh she came out
grab them yeah grab them yeah she
slammed them down bro shout out to that
guy from keeping this component
absolutely
absolutely how about she's like that kid
was 14 she goes oh is that what he's
claiming
yeah it's yeah that's rough those would
yeah it's get like the the the bird
watching one was a bad one
that video i'm glad they made it's a law
now in new york i think it's like so if
you
fall asleep like she's in trouble oh
yeah yeah yeah because if you falsely
accuse someone and it should be that you
should be that that's ridiculous you
can't if you're caught falsely accuses
yeah she's like i'm she's basically
saying i'm you know i'm gonna say this
guy's raping me
the guy's [ __ ] bird watching yeah
it's not the way she was crying on the
phone
oh my god but also don't watch birds
though you know yeah but also don't
worry
that's the birthday hold on because you
don't like birds
so what's wrong
stealing sneakers in hotel rooms
i mean what are you doing white [ __ ] for
bird watching try to elevate yourself
nah nah you don't know i want to be an
expert in birds come on
don't you guys got a mixtape to sell
so you live in new york you don't watch
or feed birds or do anything no
okay no no what do you think i wake up
follow pigeons
there's a lot better there's a game on
them like oh i can't catch a game
there's birds
beautiful birds talking look at it it's
game seven but these pigs are
hot what are we doing what are you
eating what they [ __ ] they fighting no
no you got a loaf of bread in this chest
look at them man
you watch birds no yeah so what are you
talking about
wait a second you don't watch brooke you
don't [ __ ] watch burns either
got mad at me for that my bad yeah he
wasn't saying it was a bad thing
like they have a whole community and
like oh so it's a tv show
i thought it was the only one true
there's a whole
it's a whole scene man oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
we're going to love it dude they got
special [ __ ] binoculars
oh there's a whole squad out there
watching birds yeah dude how do i
actually funny story some white [ __ ]
sure
[Applause]
there you go you know what may happen
black people might start getting into it
and then bird watching is going to
become the [ __ ] oh
cause whatever you guys get into the
next thing you know that [ __ ] will be in
japan anywhere
yeah japanese people you're [ __ ]
watching isn't that the guy
oh no no no the guy was the other guy
this guy right yeah isn't it
that's him yeah he's a cool dude he was
a very cool dude what happened to that
lady gave her
oh yeah he didn't press charges he was a
cool dude he went he's like he's
he is he's like god went to like harvard
and [ __ ] he's like legit
yeah oh get smart that was him that day
wasn't it jack two look at that yeah
he's in chase that's what i'm saying he
wakes up and works out look at those
look at those veins he'll watch what
[ __ ] yeah he's trying to attack no white
lady
no no no no no but again you're right
she was crazy it was really that video
thing you said black people wait when
you said i thought you said
crazy [ __ ] puerto rico she did get in
trouble she did like she got arrested i
think but then he didn't press charges
so they let her go
they kind of let her go yeah but she got
fired
she lost her job she got like uh refresh
she became a meme you don't want to
become a meme
yeah she doesn't have friends anymore
yeah she's [ __ ] but she
he he's so he was so cool he was like i
bet barbecue becky was watching this
like yes
and i think that i think that's how you
really make a statement you know what i
mean like
if you just let like just because it
makes you look like the better
oh yeah really emphasizes what kind of
piece of [ __ ] she is
when you're just like all you did was
hold the mirror when you forgive
somebody that's
power yeah yeah that's oh big power if
you're a general and you win a you you
go and you you let the other general
kind of you don't kill everybody then
then they're like all right you know
just let it go yeah cause then you
create resentment and
damn who's that guy on the uh all the
way to the right who's that
what does he have to do with it i don't
know how he snuck in there
all up in the videos yeah oh that's the
firm that fired her
okay get on him yeah yeah shout out yeah
she's an idiot
she was like choking her dog which is
crazy yeah
yeah he was just asking her to put the
dog on the leash that's right he's
trying to put her dog in the leash where
she
the dog should be in a leash there yeah
that's that yeah
yeah all right just stupid overall the
guy who watches birds that sounds like
something
he would be a stickler about oh yeah hey
you gotta excuse me you gotta have the
this is a bird watching
area how about yesterday me and jay were
in venice shooting that uh
thick boy commercial we got out and i
was like putting my tights on or some
[ __ ]
and there's like this little like dog
walking on venice
like on this on the sidewalk but going
into like cars and means you're like
what the [ __ ] i'm like is that
somebody's dog and this like
kind of hot mexican girl pulls up in a
volkswagen she gets out she's like is
this your dog
you could tell she was hot off the bat
like that's not my foot do i look like
another [ __ ]
this lady comes out she's like oh i own
the shop here the dog like
this is her territory like she walks up
and down no and she's like i'll get the
dog she's like get your [ __ ] dog let
out take care of the [ __ ] dog you
[ __ ] i'm like wow oh
yeah yeah wow i was like wow what did a
woman say
and then again she wasn't white she was
puerto rican
[Laughter]
the white girl looked this way oh yeah
yeah yeah
people get people get worked up over
animals i feel like right now everyone's
super testy because if coven
locked down so like
people already popping yeah people are
ready to pop off they are dude
but but if you're in new york you're
feeling pretty good because cuomo is
like all right whatever
yeah biden's elected we're gonna release
things yeah
newsome's like nah we good yeah i heard
he's i don't know too much about him but
i heard he's like he's
out of restaurants he got caught right
mm-hmm like he closed all wineries
yeah because he his kids are in school
his background is wineries he was like a
wine distributor
piece of [ __ ] yeah you know what's what
the good thing about this i think is
people
now realize how important local
officials like
you ever think about a mayor or governor
never thought about it and now you
realize oh [ __ ] they
they have some power they got a lot of
power like in some ways a lot more than
the president
the president's like out there like he's
doing the country but like
he's not going to affect you [ __ ] you
locally yeah no you had your governor's
your elected officials yeah like you
realize that oh [ __ ] i should vote man
yeah so that means but also newsom's
been laying low
he used to talk all this [ __ ] but he's
being recalled and they have to get the
15
or i'm sorry 1.5 million recall votes
yeah not like 1.3 last time
oh [ __ ] she's about to get so he was
like oh [ __ ] i [ __ ] up then he does
this [ __ ]
press conference and they asked him
about businesses he's like listen
rich people and billionaires they're
fine they don't care right they're
killing it and we're
like what right he said yeah he was like
that's my time thank you
yeah oh that is not the right thing to
say oh he's just a real
yeah when are they not killing it wow
yeah
right what do you got just no i think i
think maybe it's time maybe this is
bringing an era of storming we storm
[ __ ]
oh he's like just about
i was driving down malibu beach or
whatever the [ __ ] on the coast yeah
and he was like yeah he was like yeah
tim's like [ __ ] reese witherspoon
lives right there whatever he's pointing
out millionaires of real money over here
you think they are affected by the
pandemic and i just i looked across the
ocean and i was thinking like yo
china's over there yeah and i was like
yo how funny would it be
how funny would it be if china just
invaded malibu like stormed
reese witherspoon's house just and just
took over pepperdine just [ __ ]
they said i'm kind of already doing that
at the university yeah if you go to ucla
you're like where the [ __ ] is
the white kid yeah all asians all asians
dude crushing it in academics
but it would just be funny like and i
feel like let's storm the hype house
all the white kids and air force ones
their n-word comes up in the stone they
go
just white people dancing less than
mediocre oh
way less than yeah he's like [ __ ] how
do you guys feel about that [ __ ]
it's not the total aaron carter [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's like new kids on the block like
nuke it new edition you know
you know the new edition new kids know
that's one of my favorite stories so it
was the manager
of new edition new edition was the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] yeah i mean you know it was
ralph treasure
did you see that i didn't see it it's on
b t he ain't got beat so
they were from boston they were like
four kids from organically put together
that bad
band together right new addition bobby
brown [ __ ] yeah bobby brown
[ __ ] ralph tres van and then uh the
kid
like white kids you know cause you can't
have like you can't be a white girl in
the suburbs and have like
bobby brown on your wall your dad comes
in and it's like [ __ ] take that down
and put johnny depp up you know whatever
oh i can curt cam'ron on that wall
if i don't see vanilla eyes
so the manager of uh new addition who i
think was a black dude but he was like
he was like [ __ ] i mean i need to get i
need to
audition for white kids and create a
white band
that mimics this that sucks but like
white girls can go yeah
yeah which one do you like the dangerous
one
yeah johnny wahlberg is a dangerous one
and so that's kind of like when i watch
technique i'm like that's the same [ __ ]
same [ __ ] it's like
i'm supposed to pretend like addison ray
is an amazing dancer somewhere
in the seventh year i mean she dances
okay but she ain't doing like [ __ ]
beyonce
no not at all no it's like one word i
love when the edward comes out
yeah yeah
and i love what their dance dudes like
16 year old white girls are like pop
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] i got cruiser
cruises 16 you live in malibu what is
going on
this country is [ __ ] over
it's over man not our president [ __ ]
was on the apprentice
and then he got people to storm the
capital yeah you can't south park
couldn't right now no
hell no white people climbing the wall
i'm in the fall
wild okay so bruce willis went to rite
aid and
he got kicked out from an employee
because he wasn't wearing a mask
someone took a photo and it started
trending on twitter and people are
attacking bruce willis that could just
be because he's just like
he's sick and not being recognized he
hasn't been in a movie in a long time i
can't just [ __ ] walk in anonymous
anymore
it's a [ __ ]
what's that have to do with anything man
hard on them yeah but but also listen
dude
everybody you see yes you gotta wear a
mouse dude like even you know
i wear a [ __ ] mouth any story you
gotta wear a mask dude
i just [ __ ] spilled coffee all over
my jeans
at least they're light gray yeah what
can you do you need a napkin
he has the handkerchief he has like the
yeah yeah
he probably didn't realize it probably
forget too people forget i forget
sometimes
yeah like it's that that's down yeah i
forget like right when i walked in this
like i'll be like oh [ __ ] out of a mess
i turn around
that would be funny if like it was he
put it on as soon as someone said it but
they took the picture and yeah
journalists was like let's just run with
it oh of course
let's just say he didn't want to put his
mask on yeah that's a better story
he goes in there just without a mask
like dude you bubba you know you can't
do that yeah these days
like especially right now in la like
that is just asking but even even the
states that are a lot more open if you
go into business you still got to wear a
mat yeah yeah
you know alrighty this one is really
weird do you guys know who azalea being
of course she is they make a cry on mtv
i don't know who she is so azalea banks
is an artist she's a singer she's a
singer she is
a singer and she is in a lot of
controversy she was the one who got
kicked out of
a party because she started like calling
russell crowe
terrible things so he kicked her out she
started saying russell crowe was
racist she does a bunch of terrible [ __ ]
that people are more well-known she's
more well-known for her controversy than
her music at this point
and on i believe it was wednesday or
tuesday she went on instagram live
dug up her dead cat and started to boil
him why
holy [ __ ] because she said she wanted to
bring him to
a pop pawn shop to like get it
taxidermied
oh my god because she's gonna move out
of california so she did all of this on
instagram live and it was taken down wow
she's
crazy someone catches the she's the bald
one and she also went out of her way to
say that doja cat and megan the stallion
are fake ugly [ __ ]
or i mean fat ugly [ __ ] well that's
where i draw the line
boil your cattle the [ __ ] you want i
hate cats i'm allergic to them
dosia though straight dime piece
well she always wait do they have videos
of her doing it uh you
might be able to find them on the
internet but instagram took it all down
oh
she's gonna be in trouble like animal
rights activists come at you hard
but the cat's dad's dead what are you
coming out of weird it's
it's just she always would you rather be
her or
army hammer right now you hear about the
army having stuff no
he likes to cut uh girls up and cut
their toes i think i'd rather be turns
them on
yeah like something like weird [ __ ] like
allegedly yeah
wait what cut her toes like off no he
that's what he said to a girl you said
it wrong
he he wrote in a girl's dm yeah a bunch
of girls have been releasing
like unseen dms we don't know if it's
real or fake but it's of him saying that
he is 100 percent accountable
he wants to cut off her toe and keep it
with him she's his
slave and she like he wants to have all
those really
dude we need to see people are losing it
man and he stepped down from that job
you were telling me he stepped down from
him from the job he was like he's like
i'm not gonna leave my kids for four
months to do a photo shoot or do a movie
while i'm doing
well these fake shit's going on it's
like
all right i guess responded today so the
verdict's not out whether it's fake or
real yet well but here's what's weird is
his ex's two ex came out like yeah he's
into that [ __ ]
and his ex-wife is also like i believe
those dm's are real
oh so three women but here's my
whatever i don't agree with it if that's
what he wants to do that's his thing
everyone has their fetishes but
if he's in a mutual relationship where
they're into it too obviously he's not
cutting anybody's hand and feet off and
[ __ ] their brains like you said but
that's what turns him on
should he not be able to work so can he
be in a movie
like should he lose jobs because for the
fantasies
yeah it's a good question it's weird
don't get me wrong
yeah he's never been my favorite but he
shouldn't lose jobs over
it right i don't think he's lost a job
over it yeah he's stepping
he's just stepped down oh he lost it
come on
come on you think you think lionsgate's
like yeah we're shooting next week go
ahead and take the time off buddy
we support you no [ __ ] no no way yeah
nobody wants that i know
oh and you think he's gonna get more
rolls after this you think hollywood's
come
burning down his door after this true no
his career's gonna take a [ __ ] hit
man even though they don't know if it's
real or fake
no but also if even if it's real he he's
not really doing it
yeah that's what he's into yeah there's
no record of him actually yeah doing it
he isn't
but but also but if it's a mutual like
the girl's like yeah i like when he
talks to me about cutting off my [ __ ]
ankle or where the [ __ ] he's into the
butt
he doesn't do it
that's interesting because whenever
chris hansen would go i always wondered
like they didn't do it yet
so what's the law say like because they
would all get arrested like all of those
cash flows
but they had like right they they came
there as soon as they put that cookie in
their mouth they were done
that's like all he did was eat a cookie
no as soon as he got out the six-pack of
my card's lemonade he's all you wanna
have a seat
who's this you want to tell me why
you're here today
because then then chris hansen's like if
i wasn't here what would have happened
nothing no i was going to tell her i'm
here to help her with her homework no
no he's going i was going to tell her
that
it's very dangerous out there to be
smarter he's like then why'd you have a
why's your we went through your car your
full pack of condoms yeah
again i don't know i don't know what
could happen then he goes well let's
go back to your correspondence i love
when he reads this yeah he goes uh
you're asking her here if she shaves her
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
all right can i come over and [ __ ] and
the guy's just sitting there going all
right
i'll be there at you now here you sent a
dick pic and then you said do you like
she said yes she said you will be there
at 802.
it's 803. it was saying
at that point they just go uh are the
cops outside yeah
the cops know they don't well the
winning got more populated but before
they're like yeah i'm sorry man i won't
do it again he's like cool
can i leave yeah
it's a skinny fat pedophile yeah yeah
that they do they overdo it they really
tackle them on the ground i wonder if
they're in the back like okay who's
taking who's whose turn is yeah jeff's
like [ __ ] me
bro watch this [ __ ] jeff got lead on
this one i love that he's like
can i leave he's like yeah sure go ahead
yeah and they just [ __ ]
blindside like the water boy yeah under
the grass it goes from the best feeling
in the world to the worst
like that because they leave like [ __ ]
god i learned my lesson
i learned my lips yeah yeah i'm glad you
did this thank you chris yeah like no
problem
have a good day yeah but have you seen
that dads against uh i forget pedophile
yeah yeah yeah have you seen that
vigilante so it's kind of like this
dad group who they they kind of do what
chris hansen does
they pretend they're like young kids on
the internet and then they agree to meet
him and then these dads show up like
what are you doing here and it'll be
like ladies and dudes and
they'll be like what are you doing
walgreens who are you looking for and
they're like nothing i'm sure the shop
like really and then they bring up the
text
and the guy's like oh [ __ ] and they're
filming it like you piece of [ __ ] wow
and then the guy's like i'm gonna call
the cops like cool call the cops because
we're gonna show them all this go ahead
and they can't do [ __ ] right right it's
great so is that a joke
it's like a youtube youtuber it's a
youtube channel yeah are we sure it's
not like set up
like they're like i don't think so yeah
yeah all right
because i always wondered like why chris
hanson stopped that show didn't he
i think he got in trouble didn't he or
something i don't think he got in
trouble oh did he i don't know but he
came on the
theo's show and then uh like stole money
from
yeah he like stayed extra nights at the
hotel and then like hyped up the the
check on uh no he was choice
check bones yeah i never trusted him
like 13. chris hanson went broke huh
something happened to him yeah wow
he got older too yeah it looks like a
lot older i mean that people would still
watch that show
if somebody did that show it was like
america's most wanted
right america's one i think is still on
yeah uh yeah
well he's doing another show now on uh
who chris sands uh no the america
and they caught a lot of people yeah
that show was intense yeah they used to
scare the [ __ ] out of me yeah they got
rid of cops but first 48 is still
popping
i love first 48. it was in memphis the
last time right yeah
it's either memphis or tulsa it's only
this yeah it's always in the south i'm
like dude go to new york go to the
outlets
i know yeah that's more for that man you
know what it is right now
oh it's not on anyone it was a shock
not cnn i forget what he who works for
someone now did you hear why he started
that show
yes yeah his son was like three or four
and he was murdered those jokes are
important they're like important to
society
oh they got decapitated yeah they found
a son with like his head ripped off so
it's horrible story especially as a
father it's [ __ ] talk
do you remember bait car what's that one
oh
what is it that's like
it's a great show catching criminals
yeah you're still
producing you see 75. you're seeing the
bang bus on newborn
[Laughter]
here's fourteen dollars okay
take it i guess well he's like he's like
you owe 27
or
every time y'all
dollars you say
look at this cap
they're gross the cash cab that's in new
york you know they got yeah
he's a stand-up guy right he's he
started as a stand-up and he made a lot
of money in that show
yeah dude that i feel like that's the
toughest show for the least amount of
money
it's like the question on that
question's hard really like a hundred
dollars yeah
like you have 27 blocks to go you've got
three questions wrong yeah we're gonna
drop you off
okay yeah yeah i just wanted to get home
yeah we uh i actually did an episode
comics yeah i don't think we made it to
air but they filmed they filmed a bunch
it was me and two other comics
and they set you up they're going like
we're gonna take you to the museum and
then he shows up and you're in the cash
cab and he turns around and they ask us
questions and check yeah
did you win no we didn't win we didn't
win they're [ __ ]
now you can take the cash you have
seventy dollars
or you can go for broke and double your
money yeah
it's all set up though it's hilarious oh
really they don't they don't just pull
over yeah they
they audition you oh got you for this
episode they just got three comics
and they just put us and we didn't know
what we were doing but yeah everyone
else they like cash because
if it was real i'd like to see the
outtakes yeah if i get a taxi and he
turned around like you're in the cash
cab yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] get me out give me up
there's no child
yeah drunk people get in [ __ ] what
do you know who the capital is
because in new york nobody goes the cabs
don't go to brooklyn i just realized
that would be a local reference
so i stopped myself oh yeah good good
yeah what else you got jen
okay so a former border patrol agent
recently
uh quit his job and right before he left
he put urine in a spray bottle sprayed
down his boss's desk
clothes and a bunch of his [ __ ] people
didn't know who it was but the office
smelled
like absolute [ __ ] for about a week and
it cost 400
to clean up they found out it was him
after he was or
he had already quit and now he's facing
up to a year in prison and a a hundred
thousand dollar fine
god damn wait whoa [ __ ] spraying p
on his boss's stuff he is weird we also
don't know
he pissed in like a spray he has pete in
a spray can it does not specify whether
it says or not
weird i hope it's his yeah that'd be
yours
mark your territory [ __ ] if you
get fired you that's the way to go do it
man yeah
go go hard go hard to go home oh you
think so yeah why not you get fired
[ __ ] spray the whole place with piss
me my brother used to forget this rental
place where it was they paid us like
[ __ ]
and i knew i was gonna get fired and the
our boss was just a pre just the [ __ ]
worst
he'd always smoke cigarettes like
constantly talk [ __ ] to all of us
so i took the cigarettes and stuck in my
ass so there's there's [ __ ] on the tip
of the cigarettes
and then when he i was gonna quit that
day when he came back he's like you know
your problem is
and we all started laughing that's the
thing about black people we just
curse you all out like we don't have
like some kind of
white white people you're awesome
i was a legend
i'm so confused you always just have
[ __ ] around your ass
i got really i mean i went i went i went
deep yeah
you put it in there oh yeah yeah you
took your
you took your temperature with that
center and like all of his marble
reds did it dookie covered so you cannot
miss a chocolate cover
when you stuffed it into the cigarette
not break or you got a loose [ __ ]
i just had a mission no i had a mission
i had a mission
dude
do not leave your [ __ ] pack of
cigarettes in a room alone with brendan
charles
right they will end up in his ass and
then your mouth i don't know how you got
their promotion
yeah legendary movie i got something you
want to hear about like i like it
your move matt yeah yeah what's his name
matt what was that chick-fil-a and a
black woman was cursing out the uh the
word the boston oh she was going off
bro i think it was for ranch for ranch
and it was like yeah
this is frustrating when they don't give
you your [ __ ] i think they were i think
they were charged because they charged
for
that chick-fil-a charges extra for well
she must have they
they they usually give you like two but
then she probably want a bunch more she
said that girl
she did not move she didn't know bro it
was packed that day it was
hiking yeah so she was like lady if you
can just pull up she's like i'm not
pulling up she said i'm not pulling
i waited this whole time give me my and
it was like you know the woman had to
come out she was like in the window yeah
she came out to the car she's like man
here's a free meal
free everything yeah just please pull up
talking [ __ ] she was like
i'll take the free meal i want me to go
she pulled up yeah
but again she was talking [ __ ] we just
curse y'all out we don't induce
conniving things like that i ain't gonna
piss on you though yeah that's good
yeah who we always share a cigarette
legendary bro i want to know he was the
ass
why did you think of that yeah why did
you think yeah because he smoked all the
time
because if you hate somebody just
cursing out it's not enough sometimes no
to know he's smoking
[ __ ] yeah in his lungs that can hurt him
um let's see
cat's backs let's go i made a quick tick
tock video on those air force ones
yeah i did a tick tock and now i'm going
to wait for my 5 million
check just like that exactly yeah they
make money
makes more than like a nba player
another one makes more than doctor
lawyers it's insane even a year it's
only fair though right
okay so
apparently conor mcgregor bought this
watch
while he was in uh fight island
and he took the story down from his
instagram but this is
just his newest one get robbed no
because us
oh oh interesting i want that watch
yeah i went on that is uh that that's
that dubai where they have so much oil
money like what else can we do with it
right let's make all diamond watch that
[ __ ] wow
like what are you gonna he took that
down well he probably because the
instagram probably would fly
if he didn't probably um hey again i
don't know what do you got you got
mcgregor or
i got money on connor we got my money
yeah
i'm also a poor a guy but
yeah bro i just ordered some sweats from
russo fight really should hit me up
why are you telling me my guys oh the
ali and the uh was their first sponsored
fighter ever oh oh yeah i know yeah
he may he may dust them quick right like
like he did the first time
yeah we'll see look at that one that
one's cool
that's like a snow globe on your wrist
new watch new suit
new whip alert well what's the new whip
rolls royce so if he's in abu dhabi he's
buying stuff there so they got to like
how they ship that stuff back i probably
ran it so there's the whip right there
and then he pulls up to a whip too that
watch is sick
yeah it is not my style but
that's my [ __ ] though he's a kid he
likes to spend money oh yeah yeah that's
that floyd makes money yeah he's he's
like floyd makes money though yeah he
makes money
makes money i would say smart what's he
worth so but floyd made a lot of money
he's smart floyd he flaunts that [ __ ]
but i mean
floyd's got some financial issues yeah
true there's a reason why he's fighting
logan paul but also but that's easy
money that's easy
also yeah would you eat a hundred
million would you turn down a hundred
meal for an easy fight
not if i had if i made as much money
seated i'm not fight i'm not
jumping back into camp ever again but if
it's jake listen
no i'm not doing it if i had that much
why do it yeah what let me just say
let's say in some weird world it's
probably like let's say logan paul
knocks him out
your career is oh you're getting made
fun of you're a meme for the rest of
your life
that 50-0 no one gives a flying fight
also you can get really hurt in that
sport
like for real floyd's also older yeah
like 43.
that's old as [ __ ] brady is playing at
43.
different different sports he punched
his face oh my god
have you been fighting the lighter
weight have you been fighting a lighter
weight you've been fighting your whole
life and the guys you've been fighting
for three
years yeah again if i had that money my
ego is not that small where i'm like i
need to [ __ ] this guy up for
uh for the culture he's not gonna make
100 million he but he's like
let's say he makes 50 million it's just
there's no need if i had that money
there's no need for it
yeah yeah because when you have that
much money if you just put it in the
bank your money's making money yeah and
here's the difference
connor has his whiskey line which does
hundreds of millions of dollars in
revenue
strip club yeah because floyd has made
like a billion dollars he's
already [ __ ] you should be shouldn't
he should be logan paul
yeah yeah yeah you should be all but
when he goes somewhere he has
30 people traveling as well yeah that's
why he has financial
yeah yeah
did floyd mayweather kill his baby's
mama
okay so that's the next day corona
happened and nobody
they forgot about that i mean do you
know the story yeah no she was she was
about to write a book yeah
uh she was like they were in court right
or something
and then she died in her car randomly
randomly young she's like 40 years old
they said they
randomly died in a car no health issues
nothing nothing her name was you start
with a j
again i'm gonna just be muting nobody's
ever been like yo did floyd mayweather
put corona on the world
accent i'm not saying i actually did an
overdose
yeah that's suspicious no no no
she was about to get millions of dollars
from him write a book about how abusive
he was and then
whoopsie daisy overdose overdose that's
all she never had a drug problem before
that no just sort of
out of nowhere strange right makes you
go
things that make you go things that make
you go yeah that's crazy so so yeah kind
of
gregor watch though that's that's crazy
yeah she's gonna write a tell-all yeah
she's gonna write a tell-all
damn she said she was really afraid for
her really afraid of my life
she said that yeah yeah and she was
so before her untimely death uh jose
harris was reportedly the process of
ryan tell all book which she detailed
her talk to relationship with floyd
mayweather
years of abuse unless you suffered at
the hands of the legendary boxer
friend of harris who chose remain
anonymous release excerpts of the book
uh jose dessert to have her voice heard
now more than ever yeah definitely buy
that book
uh in addition to dressing that they met
as teens
recount six violent episodes that
allegedly occurred during the
relationship
among the most disturbing accounts was
what she described as her last beatdown
which took place in front of her former
couple's three children
according to the excerpt the attack
which jolted harris out of her sleep was
allegedly fueled by mayweather's belief
that harris was seeing a man named cj
and that she was spending money on him
my eyes flew open to the sound of my own
screams pain was
uh searing through my skull when i
looked up and saw floyd
he was holding that back the back of my
hair stand over me with one hand punch
in the back of my head with the other
dragging me off the sofa pulling across
room
furniture in the living room was falling
as he pulled me like a rag doll
floyd listen to your kids you're doing
this in front of your kids jesus christ
and what about the financial stuff would
she were they in court or was did he owe
her
she was getting money 8 million you
don't think he'll pay 8 million come on
man
you can give her that yeah i don't i
know there was financial stuff there
yeah
but you got his that death is suspicious
i mean beyonce
honestly never had a dream he killed her
he killed her man hold on hold on now
yeah
let's let's let's why is this show still
big
i'm not sure i'm not sure what happened
floyd i don't know 20 mil
that's for her to pay him white medal
wrote a sweet note to his late
ex-girlfriend jose
only days before going to court
demanding her estate pay him money
the message was kind of beautiful that
he wrote on instagram he did it like
every single day every day yeah every
day every
post picture yeah just let me make it
look like i care about this
obviously about the woman i was saying
get your [ __ ] i was yeah
right before that like [ __ ] give me 20
million dollars
oh god that is i disciplined her a few
times
what yeah look the sauce needs to be
right you know that's
not my fault god that is that's intense
i forgot about that they were were they
married was it his wife not his ex-wife
i thought it was ex-wife so they were
married so what was so that he was
paying was he paying her
what what do you mean well he would have
he would have paid her like
they have kids again they all grown up
that's what i'm curious about like what
was their settlement you know like still
owe her money did he still owe her
millions of dollars
because then you know if she's gone does
he still owe her millions of dollars
i mean he is fighting logan paul so he
you know
yeah that's one less expense so she was
so she was in her car
yeah in her car that's what got in her
car in the morning
bring it up if she had a drug history
chip yeah i don't think so though yeah i
don't i think it's random
on history hyenas we used to just say it
out of nowhere randomly like there'd be
a silence
like this just this is just your
friendly reminder that floyd mayweather
killed his baby's mom
we did that for like six months during
corruption are you serious yeah it would
just make a joke
click on no evidence of drugs or suicide
it was the middle of 20 million lawsuit
at the time that's it
yeah they were in the middle of a 20
million lawsuit at the time
she died in her car in the morning after
a good night's sleep
shower put the lotion on fellas yeah you
know how it is
put a nice lotion on yeah had some
farina oatmeal
oh that that's what got into the
cadillac [ __ ] that floyd money paid
for boy doesn't like that
yeah yeah somehow fentanyl
what do you think he used to re she was
the one he went to jail over
yeah two months and he loves her though
instagram
when he posted those shits that's like
when celebrities post like liberals
i'm just saying when he posts that
whenever you see a celebrity post like
real liberal [ __ ] on the ground
everyone's liberal for the gram yeah
then they get in their accountant's
office they're like
okey-dokey hide my money
from socialism yeah so he was posting
that like hey i loved her
it could don't you think six posts of
her is a little
sick not really thou doth protest too
much
oh smoke screen couldn't have been me it
couldn't have been me
there's six posts about how we loved
each other even though we were in the
middle of a 20 million dollars
yeah she don't have 20 million dollars
hold on hold on p diddy when kim died he
post
every day when when pete did he killed
kim yeah
i mean are we children do you guys do
you guys think santa's real
who do you think killed biggie mr rogers
no no
people kill each other over money okay
but i'm saying wait you
you really think that was the thing with
diddy no i don't know anything about it
yeah i'm sitting here like what the [ __ ]
is going on oh i'm not crazy i'm not
[ __ ] yeah i don't know
i don't know but good point but floyd
mayweather
come on man again that could be the same
thing he's gonna make it go
and it's a good point that he's like
i'll fight logan paul here's the news
yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah i got tate
davis
it dude nobody taught it's crazy it is
weird
easy it was bigfoot i mean tell me how
he didn't kill her
his stories were how didn't floyd
mayweather kill his baby's mama he was
how you know it like the motive is just
like crazy so obviously
it's just so [ __ ] transparent it's
almost as transparent
as that the ccp communist party gave us
corona
to take taiwan hong kong
okay hong kong they passed that new
security law they're [ __ ] taking it
yeah yeah they don't give a [ __ ] yeah
used to be a girl brenda you got
something to tell us
about wednesday's show should women
fight in men's mma
you got away with it long enough my
friend
six foot two [ __ ] tell us
the truth you
i'm in it i made it man yeah this one's
interesting though no
no no no here's what's crazy i totally
forgot about it
exactly i didn't think of it but and you
but you did hear the story right yeah so
did it ever cross your mind did you ever
like suspect it no i was like what she
died that's crazy and kept going kept
going because then
covet hit like the next day yeah cause
the news was like shut your mouth stay
at home yeah right that's my important
but it's nuts wow that is crazy i mean
like no investigation
fentanyl who's got fentanyl besides
prince
like prince and michael jackson the only
people or doctors get their hands on
fentanyl
you can't just get your hands on
fentanyl can't just get your hands on
[ __ ] fentanyl
yeah you're making too much sense so
much [ __ ] again
again all this is you guys want to let
911 i'll be here all week we did
we did what else you got yeah let's just
change the subject
who dies in their car outside their home
in the morning going to starbucks yeah
of fentanyl who's who's doing fentanyl
in the morning before coffee
yeah before a morning muffin you know
what let me do it
let me do an overdose of fetanol the
[ __ ] that killed michael jackson
no evidence of drug or suicide so it's
very very
but they found fentanyl in her system
yeah that means yeah why would yeah why
would she just conspiracy is real man
this one is like kind of like yeah
that this is as obvious as hillary being
a shape shifter
i mean it's all there it's all there
no suicide note he accused her of having
drug problem in the past but she
did not have any drugs or evidence of
use of drug use when she when they
looked through
her car yeah no she put it in her it was
in the morning too right like what time
i think it was in the morning so it's
like yeah you know just doing a little
fentanyl with my coffee
yeah yeah just a little oatmeal and
fentanyl
see your americana she said she would
fear for her life
they were in a 20 million lawsuit she
was releasing a book that talked about
how he
committed felonies by beating her he
went to jail for it uh
yeah yeah she was a gorgeous woman
who had money beautiful young
she already had money she got hit his
money
yeah three kids you know she was
releasing the book for no
financial gain really i guess because
she had money god this is dark
yeah where else you got jim she got
friends
yeah what else she got someone's
connected to floyd
well i'm just saying again shout out to
dejuan yeah oh yeah what am i
[ __ ] malik well
this might be the only moment you've
heard have you heard it
anywhere and i'm in the business and
you're in the business and you killed a
woman
comedy here jesus christ
like you were an expert in your [ __ ] man
you're countered you started a podcast
became a comedian
she's gone
yeah producers are asian colvin come on
kids farting doesn't want people to
think about real [ __ ]
kids black co-hosts black lives matter
yeah conspiracy people are funny dude
they find connections anywhere
newspapers upstairs [ __ ] hiding in
all the stories you can't see the story
that you're supposed to do
brandon kai brendan shot killed
mayweather's baby
that's exactly good
hillary clinton shape-shifter and then
you start reading it like man makes love
yeah yeah so i gave you like yeah
brendan does like
[ __ ] bill clinton was on that plane
it all comes it also has been on the
plane he has been on playing with him
and all of them for a while they were
all the conspirators were coming back to
epstein
you noticed that they were all coming
back to epc sammy so
[ __ ] turned away he was on epstein he
was with he was two blocks from
epstein's
is that what salsa was no i'm just
saying that for a while it was like
everyone was raping kids if you if you
if you were
like in the same city as epstein you're
like he's raping cancer
he's been to florida sami sosa lives
he's in florida oh god
all right oh wow yeah i just looked at
you all i saw was google so it's like
that's it right
uh so speaking of covid if do you guys
know anyone that lives in orange county
yeah yeah and if they're over the age of
65 they can now get
the covet shots the vaccine i guess you
download that app athena
and they could they can do it right now
if they wanted to here's what i was
talking about that is
so with the vaccinations because they're
like only old people that want to get it
enough people didn't want to get it they
had to throw away a [ __ ] ton of the
vaccine what
that sucks that's insane you know you
get to get inside or just give those to
some of the young people that want to
get it too because they need it they
have underlying health care just like no
no we're gonna throw them away that's
weird you gotta wait your turn like oh
that makes sense way to go everybody
huh way to go government roll out mm-hmm
and you have to get it twice
i didn't know that but yeah you have to
get it twice you get one and then three
weeks later you get the best yeah
now they're saying it doesn't matter
when you get the second one yeah the
next day two months later they're saying
now
the cdc is like oh it doesn't matter
just get just get both
[ __ ] and then now they're really milking
it like or you might get a super one if
you do it three times
get the third it's like it changing
every day man so so weird
all right james harden i guess is going
to be opening up a restaurant
this month ended this morning no he just
got traded to brooklyn
which is going to be crazy so it isn't
so i'm all for it yeah durant him
and kyrie but kyrie just he got fined
big right like a million dollars uh he
for 80 to 800 thousand dollars
and uh we had to play with fifty
thousand or yeah
yeah i mean if they're healthy they're
winning a chip no nobody are you serious
who's beating them lakers are you have
you been watching basketball
they're not jealous he's a sports fan no
they're i mean
kevin durant dude he's healthy that dude
i mean that's playing in the league no
he's not yeah
yeah hey he's a slim reaper come on yeah
it's it's
kyrie and hardin are you serious come on
is a great defender underrated dude and
in the playoffs
durant comes to play no who durant
durant the ramp put lebron to sleep
oh yeah yeah slice that's like brandon
schaub's last
fight i watch on youtube
he came down
the best player on the planet the durant
is a killer so you must not know when
when
who comes alive in the playoffs he
turned off all social media and
becomes superman lebron rumored
shooter ray allen all-star one of my
favorite players
bang okay jesus almost lost and it was
really just because of a mistake
that popovich made by taking him out
taking him
off before everybody over coach the
overcoaching woman but it was like they
should have lost that one okay so
then they almost lost again to dallas
and then the super team
that you said super team dirk nowinski
and the geriatric guru
beat [ __ ] dwayne wade in his prime
best [ __ ] two
top five two guards of all time dwyane
wade lebron james and chris botch in his
prime
first team all in three first team all
nba first
game a [ __ ] nazi science experiment
jason kidd with a colostomy bag
jj barrera jc kid
i don't know they had a four foot chicks
or [ __ ] brazilian guys
forgot about [ __ ] hall of famer jj
barrera
he was on the team to my bad jason
oh and also uh jason terry and also sean
marion he was 46.
it wasn't 40 46. they beat the lakers
yeah they
had to beat the lakers okay so again who
was on the lakers at the time
they had pal gasol andrew bynum kobe
bryant rrp
yeah phil jackson and you bite him on
that team
no way the heat should have won that no
way
not with
like nothing but flawless what i thought
was donald trump's fault
i mean whose fault he goes back to the
connection
who which series did michael jordan ever
lose
y'all keep saying that which series
his dad just died he lost a lot of money
in gambling i swept this
barney banging white women you know how
that is i don't i don't know how that
was his wife and started banging a white
woman [ __ ] powers for a year
yeah he lost his superpower
[Applause]
mojo he got it back next year came back
blew everybody out he lost one series he
didn't play the whole year he came back
right before the playoffs they weren't
jealous but look at look at who he
played in the finals he has a listen all
right
let's look at him
none of them teams
you know you're you're a big sports fan
especially basketball i played
basketball so
especially basketball so he played
especially
yeah you're not making a strong argument
when you said he got beat by super teams
he got beat by dirk nowinski
he was made in the last kevin durant
former nuts okay wait wait wait
he could barely get off the floor he
could shoot he was a great player but
you're talking about
dwyane wade nobody get nobody
understands how good dwayne
has there been a two guard who has more
blocks all time than dwyane wade
great defender top five two guards
without a doubt
name me naomi who is saying who's the
better two guard
jordan that's it right maybe rick barry
who else
maybe three who else is a two girl who's
the top i mean dwayne wade will be born
you wouldn't be
shy i'm sorry i forgot kobe i forgot
kobe russell clay thompson
clayton now he's not there yet man
listen to dwyane
he's a great shooter but i mean which
dwyane wade dwyane wade member oh six
you
carry the team by himself with him yeah
he had a geriatric shack he carried them
do you remember
how old are you man did you watch the
series i watched this series but for one
day
yeah they had everything yeah wait pull
[Applause]
and he won a championship dirk and
listen dirk and he
avery johnson can't coach let's just get
that out the way i'm said it and we
should have been getting this mad about
[ __ ] floyd mayweather killing his
baby mama
there's a dead innocent woman who's a
victim here
and we didn't even care about that [ __ ]
allegedly let's keep the edge
best two guard is jordan and kobe then
it goes dwyane wade
so it's also so you you're putting me
even higher than me yeah three yeah you
saved top five
top five
[Applause]
your honor i have a conflict with my
attorney right he's doing work
and joining fans
we have a strong argument man jordan
okay has there ever been a two guard who
was just as good
all defensive player of the year while
he was held the scoring title no
no okay so not only was he the best
offensive player of all time
whenever he wanted the best defender of
all time during the toughest error
in the league where you could cl have
you ever seen that kevin mchale foul on
her rim
that was a common foul yeah yeah nobody
was kicked out
nobody was fine i said to him how many
times was jordan hurt during error
one he had a sprained ankle one year
that was it the whole defense what was
how what was
pistons defense what was the jordan
rules what was the jordan rules when he
heard him yeah heard him yeah still 50
on you
you ever seen lebron you go
no he didn't no no he does not do that
that's james horton that's james horton
hairline
his strategy was hit him okay that was
his new and he still beat him
okay hall of famer isaiah tom uh isaiah
thomas
probably the best probably the best one
of the best point guards
hated on him look at that team joe dumas
isaiah okay
did he take down bird bird mikhail
parish uh are they better than the
people that yeah
yeah are they better than that are they
better than directions are they better
than curry
price cavaliers are they better than
curry no
yeah because it's it's [ __ ] tennis
now
[Applause]
it's not even basketball it's more
skillful can we agree yes
okay okay wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait okay okay okay we
agree with that all right let's just
calm down take a second
let's let's use our thinking right now
okay so it's more skills than me and
you're all right i've been emotional
because it's just like i hated george
it's like this the argument's ridiculous
what i mean did you see how old were you
when jordan was playing uh well
i was like six or seven yeah you just
don't know man but i'll watch i mean
it's like
you watched it you've never seen
anything like that in your entire life
i seen the last dance it was okay now
i'm saying this i'm saying this you
honest
okay lebron james and the more skillful
nba
name a more dominant player than him you
can't think of anyone
and then they always give you the
argument you put lebron james and jordan
era here probably average
he's still average 30. absolutely in my
i might on my all-time i'm put i put him
two or three behind jordan jordan kobe
if if you have one shot left you're
going lebron you're going kobe okay
let me all say that but does that but
does that go comes out
five
so kobe basically won that one he had
what do you have lamar odom yeah and
then
was he dating a kardashian i mean
phil jackson's on the floor but he so he
got two rings oh what's that guy
uh uh what's bruce uh said sasha vulgate
remember that guy come on yeah yeah
[Applause]
did kyrie have yeah forty four forty
four points but how many how many lebron
had
forty four four points lebron
who was capable of 44 points hit the
game-winning shot
when did jordan ever play with a guy who
averaged more than 17 points
he didn't because scottie pippen was
primarily a defender
and eight off of jordan wait no he
didn't yeah
but george keep saying that without
jordan he would average 14. he'd be as
good as robert rory wait hold
they got robbed let's be honest they got
robbed new york against new york
can we jay you agree with me they didn't
get robbed
but it was a good they had cuckoo they
had a good team so wait wait i love how
you oh wait so that's what jordan you're
trying
to manage that's what jordan retired
lebron leaves cleveland or lebron leaves
miami the same
heat team they barely made the play they
didn't even make the playoffs that year
so so so lebron great player okay he
carries there listen
you look me in the eye straight and you
tell me you think jordan with the bulls
would have ever
lost to dirk nowinski's yeah
i just want to walk away with that yeah
that's the first person i've ever seen
uh
me by a lot of people lebron is great
dude lebron is great
two three is two three man but i mean if
he win he's going to win this entertain
he's the second or third better
best all-around player of all time the
defense also is a little suss
out of twice michael jordan locked
everyone down maybe the best defensive
on ball isn't he better than lebron is
he better than lebron you know now look
me and my goddamn
straighten out okay michael jordan
is better at defensive m ability because
you're talking about guys so absolutely
[ __ ] literally you're questioning not
too easy why can't lebron can go
[Music]
probably as good or better than anyone
who's ever played the game
while he was the best offensive player
of all time he
is black jesus
i disagree with that lebron is a better
defender in jordan
one through five lebron if he focuses on
defense and we see
that so did he get robbed did he get
robbed did lebron james ever win
defensive player
he got robbed twice so you know the
player of the year while he the league
in scoring who
does that has he even made a defensive
team i don't even know
no he did not but again that's a good
last year
he's getting wrong jay is he getting
robbed be honest he got right he said it
he's a better defender than people give
him credit for her but
he's not playing you're not putting
lebron on the best player
all the time that like jordan took the
best guy whoever was jordan's like i
like i got him i got him are you
one through three you don't have to ask
him
no i'm saying one through five lebron
james that's a terrible argument
you're basically saying because of his
size and he can
guard four and five that makes him a
better defender no he that's like saying
because he can't [ __ ] beat up [ __ ]
more skillful more skillful players not
really not as good as mighty mouse i'm
just saying that's the
thing yeah yeah that's the argument it
doesn't that that
the logic of that argument doesn't make
sense your argument's weak
i mean we can bring up this uh this uh
statistics i like you got me [ __ ] up
now
you have the stats though you bring up
listen lebron james on a skillful point
guard and you put
kobe i mean you put uh jordan over there
he's not making the same
dominance are you serious lebron shut
down oh my god
have you watched jordan playing now
jordan was jordan was he was i
i'm not saying he's like he's high he
was just stone
now give him too much credit love his
[ __ ] icing games cleveland cavaliers
breaking hearts taking your shots how
come you don't wear no bronzers
i don't see any lebron shoes i got one
pass no kidding no kids collecting
lebrons
yeah well the new ones are kind of dope
oh yeah did you get them
no i didn't get them exactly dude there
was it might be waiting in line for
those
nobody's waiting in line for them you
know what they're crazy well
i like them on the court off the court
is apparel no i'm not liking it but i'm
again
michael jordan was the most famous
person on the planet for a little bit
he was the most famous lebron's up there
though he is up there lebron's two or
three man i mean like people act like
when you say
jordan he's a complete [ __ ] lebron
fans go like it's crazy it's like
come on man we're talking about a guy
did six if he never left okay he got
six right and easy storm rolled dude
storm stormed absolute hall of fame
teams not just players team back then
every team was stacked the cavaliers
were stacked mark price craig eelo brad
dougherty
hot rod williams larry nance
yes i mean that's a stacked squad
[ __ ] they everyone they played with
stack the pistons
okay so he got six okay he left for two
right you telling me if he didn't leave
for two he wouldn't have eight
and then if you watch the last dance if
they let that team play for one more
that's nine then we'll start talking
almost bill russell numbers
so and we all know he would have got the
two if he stayed there would be no rings
in houston
yeah when he left kim elijah was like
finally you know what i mean
well that's it's like when a [ __ ]
headliner moves to theaters you're like
now i can get some [ __ ]
weekends i mean nobody's winning when
jordan was in the league man and lebron
when he goes to the finals you're like
yeah let's see
let's see if he wins it's so dominant
listen
he's lost six times in the finals only
once with the how many times the cavs
make it
i'll give him that that was a shitty
team he carried them out he beat the
hell out of detroit and no one
gave him a there was the underdogs that
year when he once scored twice
but also the east has been weak for a
long time so he lost one with
one with the cavs right yeah the spurs
yeah i don't know yeah
you talking to the wrong guy yeah and
that was good because i
was gonna google him she does have a
computer
right now you're not the guy i'm looking
for for fast looking forward with the
truth
in the computer no i got you guys so you
lost spurs outside
he lost his purse didn't then it was the
mavs then his golden state
twice right that was his only four
losses no how many losses he did four
i throw six six oh six i'm sorry wait
i'm tripping he's
lost three times to go to state he did
miami oh there's the spurs again the
spurs again yes twice to the first first
three times in mind okay and then the
maps yeah yeah we're right that's six
right wait update that that's uh four
it's four and six yeah he's four now we
got the losses yes
he's look man he's he's just six
credit like he's still three and six
give my man his credit yo come on man
he's lost
he's lost he's gonna win this year
[ __ ] he's gonna win sixty percent of
the time he's in the finals
you think uh you think uh the nets are
gonna figure out
no you don't have a [ __ ] i think they
will i mean if kyrie just like
can just say the world's around for like
half a year
i mean the kid doesn't need a mental
break he may need i don't know that he's
crazy man he's crazy he's like crazy but
he's so
good yeah i mean he's so good well
that's why everyone puts up yeah
when did lebron ever win just one more
one more okay
when did lebron ever win a title without
another
first team all nba player on
the game has changed the game has
changed today i mean you know that
so you can have this team you've been on
had another guy who could give you 40.
but okay look at that look he just won
another one with
a d maybe the best player all around in
the league right now i'll give you that
but everybody says
[ __ ] girl yeah he's [ __ ] good i
think one thing
he's [ __ ] good this is what's going
on nobody can he's the guy he's the only
guy in the league nobody can hold
yeah you can't hold him you can't if
he's healthy what do you do with kyrie
irving but yeah
yeah steve nash that's i think it's
going to go come down to coaching
in the uh in the championship you're
right i mean l.a
it's going to be definitely but i'm
going brooke i'm going with durant
if he's healthy he's he who who did you
bet
malik uh nick three yeah nick davis
three three k
three k damn did not say no
i said no bet right i thought that's a
bad that's a bet
that's a bat you got a bet yeah wait you
put 3k um
later i didn't i didn't know this was
going to happen i didn't know yeah
what that what was it that nets were
going to get hardened all right oh right
but again i'm not
worried because they'll have a bench and
again you you gave up again
well let's see okay we'll see you i mean
i rehash it
yeah yeah good argument though yeah yeah
yeah
it was very mainly here
let me see the winner survey set
[Laughter]
james harden opened up a restaurant
that's not even open yet he's getting a
bunch of negative reviews
he has like a ton of one-star reviews
even though it's not even open yet
because he must move to the next yeah
oh yeah i bet it's good food i'll go
right there yeah
uh speaking of texas not in houston but
san marcos texas
uh two weeks is that two weeks away uh
two weeks
january 29th and january 30th
that's two shows friday two shows
saturday me and the crew special guests
tfac k i'm sorry f-a-t-k-z.com or
you can still use t5k.com to get your
tickets all thing uh think boy related
thick boy
specialized collab drops next friday i
can't [ __ ] wait we just did a
commercial for it
these people were in it it's going to be
fun man think boy.com for all your thick
needs
calm he's not touring right now remember
he said that
pay attention just gotta double
we're out of here
95s air max classics been getting them
every year almost having every color
except the original because now they're
too expensive but i did rogan so maybe
i'll be able to afford
[Music]
are them nice
i brought the heat today because i know
giannis was coming so i got the
unicorn of the dunks those chunky
donkeys
super chunky super donkey
that's your size small that's when he
said blackheads fitness shoes i'm a
black guy
alex b um rolly boy
i got my favorite sweatshirt nothing
happens overnight true start i got to
try this guy's jordan ones low top you
see me
oh yeah all right cool
game game man
um that's all you need to know uh
nike uh cortez's step-by-step oh yeah my
dad bought me
100 keeping 100 100. yeah
all right thanks dude oh dude so much
big j what's up
these guys need to learn to respect the
new balances
they always want to talk [ __ ] about them
these are the 992s
and the classic i mean this is about as
classic of a
new balance you can get nice 992.
the gray that's the original it's like
the air force ones and all white
it deserves that type of respect oh yeah
and i demand it